[Music]
in the night from thursday to friday
they die as cast
many films which have been waiting for a
long time were postponed
but this time it doesn't only affect one
studio but almost all of them
huge chaos which we will put in order
for you in the following list the first
one is christopher nolan's
tenant which should have been released
in mid-august and which caused a real
domino effect due to its postponement
as some insiders report warner brothers
is now aiming for the end of august at
the earliest and released on labor day
weekend in the usa at the beginning of
september seems quite realistic
many people ask themselves why warner
brothers doesn't simply postpone the
movie to 2021
as is the case with many other hollywood
movies but wanna would definitely like
to release the movie this year to bring
some life back to the cinemas
many things indicate the tenant will be
released outside the usa at the end of
august and in the usa on the labor day
weekend of september 4th to 7th
2020. disney in particular is making
some concessions and is postponing 17
films at the top of them is mulan
actually the film about the chinese
warrior should have been released in
august just like tennant however
now the official decision was made to
postpone it indefinitely
a bitter setback after all many fans
have been waiting for the disney
blockbusters since march
also the still unnamed star wars trilogy
will now come later on december 22nd
2023 which means an additional year of
waiting for fans and this yet unnamed
disney live action movie displaces
avatar 2 from its launch date and will
now be released on december 17
2021 which means that not only the
second part is affected but also
all avatar movies will be delayed by a
whole year avatar 2 will be released on
december 16th
2022 editor 3 on december 20th 2024
avatar 4 on december 18th 2026
and the last part on december 22nd 2028.
james cameron made a statement on the
official avatar instagram page
according to him the main reason for the
delay is the fact that the studios in
los angeles where the most special
effects are digitally processed are
currently not accessible he himself is
the one who's most annoyed about this
he thanks the fans with the words irayo
which means thank you in the navi
language
sony takes advantage of the postponement
of avatar 2 and sets the date for the
spider-man far
from home sequel from november 5th to
december 17th
2021 also in fact there are two
paramount films that should have been
released this year
first a quiet place 2 will not be
released this august but on april 23
2021 while top gun maverick will have to
leave its date shortly before christmas
2020 and will be released on july 2nd
2021. other new dates from paramount are
jackass on september 3rd 2021 and sonic
the hedgehog 2 which hasn't had an
official date yet
on april 8 2022 a real horror message is
also the postponement of conjuring 3.
actually the third part of the popular
film series should have been released on
september 11
2020 but now june 4th 2021 has been
chosen as a better date a first trailer
for conjuring 3 is therefore a long way
off
also fans of dc have to be patient
because the production of the movie
black adam which is already planned
since 2008 is delayed as well the main
reason here are not any pandemic related
restrictions but the schedule of the
rock according to a recent report of the
hollywood reporter
dwayne the rock johnson will first be in
front of the camera at the end of 2020
for the netflix thriller
red notice for which the shooting has
already started briefly and is now
pausing
as the us magazine reports johnson will
first finish red notice before he can
start shooting black adam so the filming
star in the late summer announced by the
rock in april is now cancelled and fans
have to cope with another disappointing
news from hollywood
hopefully we were able to shed some
light on the situation for you after all
the schedule of
almost all upcoming hollywood movies has
been distorted quite a bit we can only
hope that we can finally expect the
dates mentioned above
but of course everything depends on the
pandemic and the resulting restrictions
netflix is apparently planning a new
blockbuster in espionage style and the
californian company is willing to pay
a lot for it the streaming service wants
to spend up to 200 million us dollars on
it the reason for the huge budget is
quite obvious
behind the camera the two russo brothers
are sitting in the director's chair
and in front of the camera we will see
ryan gosling and chris
evans among others the film which is
supposed to be the start of a new
franchise will be called
the grey man and is planned to be spy
thrilled on the style of james bond
the story is based on a 2009 novel by
mark greenie about former cia agent
court gendry who now works as a hitman
of course the authorities notice that
and so gentry's former cia colleague
lloyd hansen is set upon him
afterwards they start a cat and mouse
game that extends over the whole globe
allegedly the roles are already chosen
ryan gosling plays the villain and chris
evans the law and order
the shooting of the grey man will start
next year so release before 2022
seems unrealistic after the
disappointing end of game of thrones
after season 8 many fans worldwide have
been waiting for new
more satisfying content around george rr
martin's franchise for quite some time
especially after the planned spin-off
series the long night or blood moon with
actress naomi watson was completely
cancelled last year
it's slowly time for a new story as was
announced a few days ago the next
project
house of the dragon is in the planning
stage the miniseries will be the prequel
to game of thrones and will also be
based on martin's fire and blood book
series
according to rumors the series will be
about the civil war during the reign of
the targaryens of the seven kingdoms
which means it will be set about 300
years before the events in game of
thrones
allegedly hbo was currently looking for
two actresses for the leading roles
ryner targaryen who wants to ascend to
the iron throne alongside their
half-brother aegon ii
and alison hightower the mother of aegon
ii however
we must be careful with the information
about the cast because so far
it is nothing more than rumors that have
been spread the series is supposed to
consist of 10 episodes in total and is
expected to be released in 2022 we are
curious of this time it'll turn out
better than the series with nomi watts
keanu reeves and alex winter will soon
be back together in front of the camera
for the third
bill and ted part as we found out a few
days ago the distributor will bring the
film to the cinema but will also give
the fans the opportunity to watch the
movie from the comfort of the living
room via video on demand
the whole thing was cleverly announced
recently and should please many film
fans
after all this is the first major film
where fans can decide for themselves
whether they want to go to the cinema or
rather watch the film from home
actually a pretty clever idea because
this way you don't depend on the
openings of the movie theaters and still
generate
solid income through video on demand the
us release of bill and tat face the
music is september 1st
[Music]
2020
[Music]